yesterday on earth day we host an event
smarter students for a smarter planet
the focus was on combining IBM's
technology resources and columbia
academic programs specifically
engineering alongside science business
and law to prepare students to enter a
job market that is looking for engineers
and apply scientists to create more
sustainable buildings electric grids and
transportation today this panel will be
specifically addressing the issue of the
smart grid and electric car I want to
thank each of the panelists for
participating in this important
discussion on the future of private
transportation in New York and all other
major metropolitan areas in this country
at this time I would like to introduce
the house of today event day big walls
who will introduce each one of the
keynote speakers and panelists David's
director of the Center for computational
learning system the center is a world
leader in machine learning and data
mining research with a focus on the
application of this research to specific
real-world challenges among the end
electric power grid Dave leads a group
of researchers in smart grid technology
who are working closely with both Kong
Edison and the US Department of Energy
dave has served as president of the
American Association for artificial
intelligence and is a fellow of the
Association for Computing Machinery he
is a member of several government and
academic advisory boards as well as the
NSF computer science advisory board
please welcome David walls thanks fanny
and good morning everybody I'm very
pleased to be part of this exciting
event and I think historic event I've
been a car lover as long as I can
remember when I was 11 my grandfather
taught me to drive his 1931 ford model a
truck which had been shortened to serve
as a tractor and his farm in Maine and
throughout the 50s by friends and I
eagerly anticipated every new radically
different car model and looked for them
on the road as they arrived
we drew and shared pictures of our
fantasy vehicles and Lobby my parents to
get the flashiest and most powerful
models I could do without huge success
but better than what they would have
bought themselves all this time I also
read futuristic our articles about
electric cars in popular science and
Popular Mechanics and you know this
seemed like an exciting future as well
as an exciting pests and maybe 110 years
ago there were electric cars but but
they were gone by the time I was a kid
for sure the first car I owned was a 19
65 Mustang sorry GM but my uncle was a
Ford dealer so we were sort of a Ford
family I personally added Carroll Shelby
aftermarket modifications to it highrise
aluminum manifold holley four-barrel
carburetor free flow exhaust system and
manifolds and the body stiffening and
suspension modifications with the help
of some professionals over the next
three decades I owned mostly a
succession of family haulers not not so
fast anymore and over that period we've
seen an amazing improvement in engine
efficiency due primarily I think to
information technology like electronic
control of everything as well as
simulation and optimization of all
designs but despite the two major oil
shocks we've had during that time and
wide publicity about the role of cars in
global climate change most of the
increases in engine efficiency of God to
make the cars more powerful and only
secondarily to improve engine efficiency
energy usage rather as a side note it
interestingly I think most today most
family sedans would handily outperform
my customized Mustang which is kind of
amazing but they only get modestly a
better gas mileage only during the past
decade have we really started to see
change with the introduction of hybrids
but even till today electric cars have
remained perpetually futuristic well
today that future is finally here with
the impending introduction of the Volt
our focus for today and I think more
widely we are on the verge of a really
remarkable
era of automotive innovation we have a
great panel today to discuss that we
have a chance to learn about what's
happening and what's coming from a
number of the key innovators in this in
this area and we'll also hear about the
effects issues and challenges raised by
these technologies so I'm very pleased
to introduce our first speaker a keynote
speaker which is John John Gilbert John
is the second vice president and coo for
the Rudin organization Rudin is a very
prominent New York developer that has
about 10 million feet of commercial
space and 18 apartment buildings before
he was a Troodon management mr. Gilbert
was president of the rent stabilization
Association and he has served in several
capacities for the new york city
government agencies he was appointed one
of the initial members of the New York
State real estate board mr. gilbert's
chaired or co-chaired several task
forces on rebuilding telecom
infrastructure and security and serves
on Mayor Bloomberg's task forces on
energy policy and on improving the
city's emergency response and security
is also on the mayor's new broadband
committee chairs in New York building
Congress energy committee and as an
officer of the grand central partnership
and a trustee of the New York Hall of
Science he's also involved in the do a
project with coned & M Columbia and it's
my honor to welcome him to give the
keynote some good morning everyone happy
to be here and sorry i delayed everyone
trying to get up here I think today is
kind of a historic moment because we we
really are at I kind of go back to 1892
and and the chicago world's fair when
much of what we we see today and i
recommend the book devil in the white
city that talks about this but much of
what we know is the modern urban city
today was first disclosed to the world
it was the battle between Tesla and
Edison over
alternating and direct current Tesla won
that battle we think there's some that
think that direct current should should
be brought back and that's for a later
discussion it was the moment when when
Walt Disney's father first saw a ferris
wheel and then ultimately influenced his
son to go into the development of
amusement parks it was all about the
distribution of water distribution of
electricity distribution of natural gas
and it's that glimpse that moment in
history that that I think we're at right
now because in my own vernacular I think
it's time that that mr. Tesla gets
introduced to mr. Metcalf and that the
creator of alternating electricity
alternating current electricity gets
introduced to the to the inventor of
Ethernet and that we create
interoperability between those two
networks so that we truly can begin to
influence electrons with photons and
that ultimately off of our blackberries
and off of our iPhones we truly can
ultimately make smart decisions about
the purchase of electrons and about the
management and of our of our electricity
consumption and ultimately our footprint
of carbon the discussion today is really
about electric cars and for us as as
kind of dumb real estate guys we look at
that is how do we make our garages into
charging stations that may sound easy
you know we just create a bunch of plugs
and allow these these cars to plug in
but it's it's it's actually more fun and
more creative than that because as we
really begin to look at these cars as
they're charged and their batteries are
charged that what do we do with that
charge if they pull into our garage is
loaded can we transfer that that that
load to the grid can that can those
electrons be ultimately distributed
elsewhere and then ultimately can we
program those charging devices to
ultimately allow those folks who have
pulled into our garage
just to leave when they want to leave
with a full charge how what influences
how does that impact the grid how does
that change the load profiles of the
grid on a micro level in terms of that
building but ultimately the overall grid
as its distributed throughout the city
very very important questions and I
think it's it really is that moment we
in the real estate business we have been
struggling with how do we distribute
photons and electrons since the early
90s and clearly it it first was
telecommunications and what we did a
Troodon was to say okay we're we're not
we're not a telecommunications company
but we have to ultimately enable
telecommunication companies to come into
our buildings on a carrier neutral basis
and ultimately distribute those photons
efficiently through the building how do
you do that well we put in cary neutral
risers that ultimately allow three
things to happen and it's all happened
out of 55 Broad Street in columbia
university was a was an early partner
with us down there but carrier-neutral
vertical risers allow the tenants to get
multiple choice of carriers that's a
good thing it allows the carriers to
have a just plug in infrastructure so
they don't have to expend capital
dollars that's a good thing and
ultimately it allows the building owner
to sleep at night knowing that they're
never going to have spaghetti in the
vertical risers again that's a very good
thing from my standpoint so haltom utley
how do we take those lessons and and
transform that forgive the pun into the
electrical grid and what we see the the
challenge is what is the infrastructure
that the property owner needs to to put
into their buildings to allow that
interoperability that I touched on visa
V the electrical distribution network
and the information technology network
to allow those photons to influence
those
drones and then ultimately how do we
create an environment where applications
once you create that infrastructure that
applications can be derived and
developed by smart Columbia engineers so
that that can be plugged into that
infrastructure that will allow these
buildings and our customers to make
intelligent decisions in terms of energy
consumption management that is the
challenge and I think it's it's a
wonderful challenge it starts in the
basement where we've got a charge and
our garages we've got to charge cars and
it moves right up the riser right to the
very top of the building in terms of
ultimately where those electrons flow
and whether they're they're intelligent
electrons or whether there's there
they're simply dumb electrons and I
think for us this truly is the the
exciting part of being involved in coned
and do ii in terms of of the smart grid
demonstration program i believe this
will change the world as we know it not
dissimilar to the World's Fair of
Chicago in eighteen ninety two we will
very shortly and some of us probably
most of us in this room are getting a
glimpse of that right now and the
metaphor that I like to use is a
Blackberry or an iPhone and if we take
that Blackberry or iPhone and we
envision that as a building that that
network of within that building we then
can begin to try to develop applications
that people will care about that money
where money can be saved and made and
that ultimately our buildings can be
made greener and the people who work and
live in those buildings can be equipped
with the tools they need ultimately to
make intelligent decisions
so that's that's our focus I should end
I could go on for a long time but I
think all of us want to hear what the
panel members have to say I end with
with a little vignette where when I
first met Robert Metcalfe the creator of
ethernet and that we all know Metcalfe's
law that the value of any network
increases exponentially every time you
add another node to that Network it is
not a linear equation it's an
exponential equation and I this was back
well mid 90s where we had just developed
55 Broad Street and it was the world's
first holy wired work environment and it
was bandwidth to the desktop and it was
in a moment of where the internet now we
all take it for granted right we're
really barely existed and it was all
about that first mile it was all about
everybody is saying the last mile the
last mile and we're saying no no no it's
the first mile that the customer is at
the beginning of the network not at the
end of the network and when you think
about first mile last mile everything
changes so I met Metcalf and I said dr.
Metcalf I just want you to know that you
know we're going to we're going to
ultimately see if Metcalfe's law works
for real estate and as we connect each
of our buildings with broadband
connectivity and as we put wireless
devices on the rooftop that gives us
parallel wireless networks that
ultimately will will survive anything
that happens in the manhole are in the
street and as we buy 32 out in the
Americas which was the original AT&T
long lines building and transform that
building into a and in infrastructure
building that ultimately today is the
landing point for all of the the data
that's coming out of the particle
accelerator insurance earned Switzerland
which then connects universities like
Columbia and other universities around
the United States having sat in an
audience not unlike this and hearing the
head of nicer net call 32 of the
Americas the equivalent of the ancient
library of alexandria
steroids because of all of the data that
was flowing through that and Medcalf
kind of looked at me said he have real
estate networks how's that going for you
and I said well we're we're not out of
the woods yet we haven't figured it out
and it wasn't until I was literally
meeting in a meeting with already crest
nur where it dawned on me that I wasn't
looking at the network of real estate
deep enough I was thinking about these
buildings and connecting buildings with
with fiber and microwave antennas and
but when you start to think of buildings
and the network of those buildings to
include every single electrical plug
that exists and to identify or to create
an IP address for every one of those
electrical outlets and then surrounding
that with middleware and software that
ultimately can be so that you can use
your mobile device to influence on off
up down whatever is plugged into those
plugs the game changes everything
changes so I would challenge everybody
here today to think about that and to
really think about introducing Nicola
Tesla to Robert mikev and to really
think about what that means and then go
back to 1892 and try to envision
yourself walking into that chicago
world's fair and seeing all of this for
the first time everything that we take
for granted the lights the water the air
conditioning the heating
none of that existed and for a moment
envision what that handshake means to
each of us as we try to make our cities
and our buildings and our homes more
efficient more sustainable and more
valuable ultimately so I thank you for
the opportunity to come here today and
hope that I've kind of ignited some some
creative thoughts and really look
forward to the panel thank you very much
okay I think at this time we'll ask
panel to come up on the stage and start
the next phase of this meeting
usually it's dangerous they surely do
that right okay our first speaker on the
panel is Lawrence burns he is director
of the roundtable on sustainable
mobility at the Earth Institute of
Columbia University but he has many
other roles currently he's also a
visiting research professor in
industrial and operational engineering
at the University of Michigan the senior
advisor to the chairman of hess
corporation he's a contract to the
National Renewable Energy Laboratory a
member of the cleantech Advisory Council
of vantage point venture partners and a
member of the Advisory Council of green
tech capital advisors up until last year
he was General Motors corporate vice
president for research and development
and for planning and strategic planning
and reporting to the CEO and president
and he was a member of the top
decision-making bodies for their global
operations and products responsible for
advanced technology and product
portfolio capacity and strategic
planning he has been an RD leader who
expanded GMS rd to a global organization
with labs worldwide and he is championed
vehicle electrification connected
vehicles fuel cells biofuels advanced
batteries and many other things which i
think will hear about so please welcome
large sprints
thank you very much can you hear me okay
I'm I'm hard of hearing i actually lost
my hearing 16 years ago and so it's
important that i come through clearly to
you know living in the world of the the
heart of hearing has its moments eyes up
my audiologist recently and I walked out
with two other patients and the woman
next to me said isn't it windy and the
guy next her said no it's Thursday and I
said so am I let's go get a beer it's
speaking of beer this is to fax if you
remember two things from my talk golfers
it turns out a golfer typically walks
900 miles a year and drinks 22 gallons
of beer that's 41 miles per gallon which
is about the efficiency of a plug-in
hybrid of a hybrid electric vehicle
which is which is pretty good so here's
what I'd like to talk about you know as
people who live in the United States I
think we realize we have an enormous
amount of freedom to move around and to
interact and it's just essential to our
economy it's essential to our lives it's
essential to creating jobs and in fact
ninety percent of our movement is by
automobile on there's 250 million
automobiles in the United States they
drive on 4 million miles of roads and we
drive them three trillion miles a year
refueling them at a hundred and seventy
thousand stations that's pretty daunting
a huge amount of inertia with respect to
how we do it and in fact the solution
that we use is about 120 years old so
John and really appreciate your framing
comments taking us back to the late
1800s because that transformation on how
we move around occurred at the same time
and the problem we have today is it's
not sustainable it's not sustainable
from an energy perspective from an
environmental perspective but also very
importantly from a safety and congestion
and affordability and equality of access
perspective the good news is that we
have a portfolio of technology solutions
that are emerging that really promise to
address these challenges
but for any of those solutions to matter
they're going to have to scale scale to
an enormously large size to compete with
the solutions that we've learned to
accept and for that to happen the market
is going to have to scale it we're going
to have to have solutions that people
really want to buy because the value
that they realize exceeds the price that
they're paying and we're going to have
to have solutions that companies really
want to supply because the cost that
they can supply it at is lower than the
price that they can get and when we can
reach that market tipping point with our
portfolio of solutions it's going to
take off and it's going to grow
nonlinearly and it's going to solve
these problems and I'm very excited
about that but we have to keep our eye
on consumers first and foremost no
consumers of mobility have a wide range
of needs driving cycles can go from
driving run in cities to driving between
cities and duty cycles can go from very
light loads to very heavy loads we have
to accept that there's not one way of
moving around there's a wide number of
ways of moving around in addition we
also have to recognize that we have to
get off of our nearly hundred percent
dependence on oil is a source of energy
for our mobility systems the good news
here is that biomass and wind and solar
and very importantly natural gas which
are all domestically produced resources
that can be deployed at very large
scales as alternatives to oil really
hold promise to provide plenty of energy
to solve these challenges but we have to
mirror up the energy with the vehicle
that codependence is extraordinarily
important now beyond energy and
propulsion systems there's also very
important class of technology and that's
connected vehicles in fact we're at a
point where the historic DNA of the
automobile internal combustion engines
and oil and mechanical machines that are
controlled hydraulically and
mechanically that operate pretty much
standalone that new DNA is he
urged it's electrically driven vehicles
using electricity with batteries and
hydrogen fuel cells controlled digitally
and electronically very very importantly
connected by connected i mean vehicles
that communicate with each other and
communicate with everything along the
roadway communicate with pedestrians and
bicyclists and when we bring these two
together and Mariette up with what is
termed the mobility Internet now this is
not just the Internet of bits of
information or the Internet of electrons
flowing in the smart grid this is the
Internet of atoms moving around and
managing that flow of movement and we
put the mobility internet with that we
really have a way to transform the world
what we're going to be seeing our
vehicles that don't crash they're not
going to run into people or bicyclists
we're going to be seeing our vehicles
that can drive themselves and so texting
won't be an issue in fact many people
would conclude that driving is the
distraction rather than texting being
the distraction and then we're going to
see the opportunity because these
vehicles don't crash to reduce their
mass significantly why is this important
it just simply is not sustainable for
our bodies weighing a hundred to two
hundred pounds to be moved round of
machines that weight 34 to 4,000 pounds
we have to change that and one way to
change that is to leverage this
communications technology so cars don't
crash week a lot of mass out of the car
and change the physics of that whole
situation now if you're wondering is
this pie in the sky I'd like to take you
to today's World's Fair the one that's
starting on may first and Shanghai the
world expo in general motors in Shanghai
automotive have a pavilion there that
will attempt to do much what like what
we heard about in Chicago and it's
showing a vehicle concept that weighs
about 750 pounds it drives on two wheels
it dries autonomously it doesn't run
into each other and we think the future
is within our grasp with that kind of
technology so I'm very very optimistic
about where we're headed and I'm
delighted to be part of the Earth
Institute
as I embark on my second career it's
great both finials can Jeff Sachs reach
out to me and this is just a marvelous
campus to be affiliated with as
evidenced by this event and I just want
to end with one advertisement on Tuesday
we're going to have our first roundtable
on sustainable mobility which is going
to begin to focus with working with
cutting-edge companies on how we're
going to bring this transformation about
as quickly as it possibly can thank you
thank you and our next speaker is RT
Krasner the way these these
introductions are long but these people
are very accomplished so bear with you
RT has his director of R&D at four power
supply at coned and he's responsible for
developing and managing rd for coned as
well as for orange and rockland county
utilities he I've known already now for
about six seven years he's been really
instrumental in and have been the
projects to be we worked on in Colombia
and has been a real visionary about the
area he manages program developing
technology for electrical transmission
distribution control center operations
substations customer operations and
energy efficiency he's innovated a
remarkable number of remarkably
innovative projects for con Edison which
you can see on the wall of his of his
area he recently authored co-authored
with Roger Anderson who's speaking soon
Albert Boulanger and John Johnson a book
called computer-aided lean management
for the energy industry on the
application of lean management
principles to the energy industry and in
the interest of time I will stop there
but please welcome RT crescent
well good morning first I'd like to
thank the organizers of the day for
inviting me to be here and to get an
opportunity to speak to this group and
especially the students I think we're
into a very exciting time much like what
John described I think it's one of those
pivotal moments I've been in this
business for a long time and I'd have to
say right now right now is the most
exciting the most interesting and I
think going to be the most significant
moment especially in the energy industry
perhaps since Edison and that's a lot to
say from someone from con Edison first
I'd like to set some context of my
sights on this yeah okay good the the
electric vehicle we see is as an
integral part of of the smart grid as
John described it so it's all about the
components it's all about the nodes and
the the smart grid is is really being
driven by a number of changes that are
happening kind of simultaneously there's
the emergence of renewable energy in the
form of photovoltaics and wind power
it's it's getting more efficient lower
costs the problem though when you look
at the interconnecting lodge systems is
that it's intermittent and unpredictable
we need to be able to manage this we
need to be able to integrate all of this
customers that have iphones and that
have all the technology won't the just
plain vanilla you could have any color
you want as long as it's black kind of
of choice just doesn't work anymore so
we need to be able to meet our customers
expectations electricity is becoming
increasingly vital both to our personal
and economic well-being I'm bullish on
electricity
I think electricity is going to be
increasingly more and more vital and
important in being able to meet the
future that we're we're all hoping and
anticipating you know I like to say that
people don't buy electricity they don't
buy the product that I've spent my
career making and distributing they
really are buying entertainment comfort
health security they're making choices
and by the way in order to enable those
electricity is an increasingly important
part of that and the next choice that
we're going to see being transformed is
personal transportation and these
electric vehicles are emerging and are
really the enabler of the smart grid
it's the smart grid each is enabling the
other this is a very vital relationship
that exists between all these
technologies in the grid I'd like to
borrow from that conversation at john
and i had a while ago the the kind of
metaphor that John used to describe
what's happening just as I T has been
the fundamental underpinnings of a lot
of information technology has been the
underpinnings of a lot of the the growth
and the the innovation and continues to
be I believe that et energy technology
is the underpinnings and growth of the
future
are we ready for the electric vehicle in
New York City well first of all electric
transportation is nothing new to New
York City 110 years ago we had electric
delivery trucks parked alongside
fifteenth Street coned and we have
pictures to prove it some of the
electric vehicles of binya but mass
transportation right now the subway I
got here on an electric vehicle and
that's the elevators vertical
transportation are the are the backbone
of the way we all move around in this
city so to New York City electric
transportation is kind of we take that
for granted I think that the vehicular
traffic in this city delivery trucks
buses are major major portion of what's
out there we do have personal vehicles
people do drive but the principal modes
of vehicles that are out in the city are
these fleets and those are ideal for
early adopters in electric vehicles the
charging infrastructure to drive those
the the length of the of the of the the
trips that those kinds of vehicles take
really fit extremely well into this
metaphor and there's a whole lot of them
and they do contribute to the noise and
the and the pollution in our city and
that would be a great great solution to
have also in New York City are private
those private vehicles are small to get
into those parking spots that we all
want for and they're used by and large
for shorter trips so they make a lot of
sense and from the viewpoint of the grid
I think we are heap there I think that
there for all but a very few hours in
the day in the week excuse me in the
year the grid is more than capable of
meeting the requirements of the electric
vehicles for quite a bit of time into
the future and for those few times
that there is there are issues I believe
there are innovations that some of them
were going to be demonstrating in our
smart grid demonstrations that John and
Roger will be referring to and there and
we need to get out of the way and let
innovation take place and people will be
coming up with solutions this is not a
problem that's insolvable i believe it
is very solvable so that pretty much
concludes the the brief comments that I
wanted to fill them in on Thanks ready
okay our our next speaker is Roger
Anderson I've had the pleasure of
working with Roger closely for the last
six years he's p eye on all the con
Edison and do a projects that have been
that have come out of the center that I
run Rogers been at Columbia for a long
time 35 years he's a senior scholar at
the Center for computational learning
systems at mc's Roger results as a
principal investigator of a group of
about 15 people who work on smart grid
related projects in my Center and he's
been working closely with coned Boeing
and others for the next generation of
smart grid technologies in the city he
was previously at lamont-doherty Earth
Observatory he founded a company called
borehole research the global basins and
for and did 40 seismic work starting the
company i think the week that oil hit
ten dollars a pound which was not good
timing so it came back to columbia
fortunately for us he also teaches
planet Earth which is a science
requirement course in columbia college
and he founded an alternative energy
program at the School of International
and public affairs at Columbia and
finally he's director of the urban
utility center at polytechnic institute
of new york university so Roger
how many of you know of Energy Star
everybody knows that I just wanted to
point out that already crest nur
invented it he's the originator huh
dragging on somebody other than myself
let's see I need to well I'd like to
build on what the first two speakers
have been talking about in terms of
trying to understand the complexity of
this machine that we are about to launch
into in 1897 the concept was pretty
simple electricity flows from the
generation downhill until it gets
unimpeded to its customers basically
like water sloshes downhill rivers to
the ocean we're in a fundamental
recharacterization of that pathway and
electric vehicles are one of the major
drivers along with getting out of this
hydrocarbon economy and more to what I
like to call the electric economy
electric vehicles are mobile and they
carry the load with them and
consequently they change they and other
sources that are distributed like like
batteries big large batteries for
example that stand alone from vehicles
change the dynamics of management of the
grid the electric grid now will have to
have the capability of receiving power
and distributing power on all ends it's
not a first adapter or a last adapter
the first mile or last mile it's every
mile and that is a very interesting
computational problem first of all and
it's an extremely interesting control
problem
and if we are not careful it could be a
god-awful mess I think that the thing
that is driving us here at Columbia so
hard to participate in the reformulation
of the electric grid in New York to what
we call the smart grid is the worry that
if we're not careful the lights are not
going to reliably come on when we flip
the switch and John Gilbert's elevators
are not going to routinely move up and
down when push the button and the little
light comes on if we screw this up we
screw up global economy it's sort of
like launching into a wall street that
we just experienced only in the electric
grid and we don't want to do that
because we're not capable of throwing
the dice in this kind of a world and
hoping that we can cope with the
complexity it's a nonlinear dynamic
machine the world's most important
machine and if we ask what are the
problems that we have to address I just
have a few of them that have impacted
Columbia in particular the machine is
like a complex family of patients and we
in fact use here at Columbia
technologies right out of our treatment
drug treatment and medical profession
there are pieces of it failing all all
day everyday components of it just like
people have knee injuries and have to
have heart checkups and all of these
things and when you have a dumb machine
one where everything is just flowing
sloshing around like we had baby up to
about ten years ago
you over treat that patient because you
can't tolerate the failures because as
you well know and in electric grid
people get hurt and so we have to we
have to put introduce the intelligence
in this kind of a system in order to
control not only the complexity of it
but the fact that it's constantly
failing it's like the b-52 everybody
knows the plane built in the 1950s still
flies every one of those planes is as
zero components from 1950 they've been
rebuilt and rebuilt and rebuilt modern
engines modern control systems that's
how they stay up in the air the electric
grid is very similar to that while there
are still some components of it that
Thomas Edison himself laid in the ground
in the streets of New York City there's
not a lot of those components and every
year we introduce more copper than we
really have to be able to afford in the
city there's already also likes to say
it's the largest copper mine in the
world right here underground in New York
introduced into that a million cars that
are electric and we really have to get
our act together about how to charge
them how to discharge them they're all
going to travel into Manhattan in the
morning they're all going to plug in and
move into John's from his apartment
buildings to his office buildings and at
night they're going to go back down into
the green garages in the basement and
they're going to go to the suburbs
transferring this massive load of
electricity that we are just now
figuring out how to handle in an
intelligent computer controlled
systematic way that's what
Thanks thanks Roger our next speaker is
a Jeffrey Sachs probably most of you
know him one of the most visible faces
of Columbia Jeffrey is director of the
Earth Institute he's Court quite a lot
professor of sustainable development and
professor of Health Policy and
management at Columbia he's also been
special advisor to he is special advisor
to United Nations secretary-general ban
ki-moon and was advisor to Kofi Annan
before that on millennial Development
Goals and international agreed goals to
reduce poverty disease and hunger by the
Year 2015 he's also president and
co-founder of the Millennium promise
alliance which is a nonprofit
organization aimed at ending extreme
global poverty in two thousand four and
five he was named among the 100 most
influential leaders in the world by time
magazine sorry from Newsweek he was
awarded the padma bhushan a high
civilian honor disturbed by the Indian
government in 2007 he's a member of the
Institute of Medicine and it's a
research associate of the national
bureau of economic research before
Columbia was at Harvard for 20 years
last but not least i should say i enjoy
reading his scientific american columns
income Jeffrey thank you very much it's
really a pleasure for me to be on this
podium and I'm here trying to soak up as
much of the wisdom as I can from this
remarkable group because my little
nation this is to try to figure out how
public policy might help this process
along if this were mainly a matter of a
thrilling technology on its own time
rolling out I think we would
to feel very confident that we're going
to get to where we need to get with a
very exciting new range of opportunities
for all of us here in New York and for
Humanity but the problem is that we're
operating against some very very serious
time lines that are a great threat and
what we're talking about here not only
should happen but actually has to happen
a lot faster than such a complex process
would normally occur and that's why I'm
listening to try to understand if and
how public policy can nudge this along
with the some alacrity and some sense of
urgency now I know given the complexity
of all of this that there are certain
things that can't be forced and Larry
burns is educating me on the generations
of technology that will be needed to
reach a certain of the crucial tipping
points that he spoke about but let me
talk briefly about a couple of the other
tipping points that we face on the
planet to frame some of the importance
of what we're talking about today
because of course we're talking about
not only the excitement of new
technological possibilities but we're
also talking about heading off some
extraordinarily dire risks that the
planet faces the transport sector is
roughly around a quarter of the
contribution of anthropogenic greenhouse
gases that are driving global climate
change and while we're all buffeted
daily by doubts of climate science and
by skepticism and by messages not to
worry and why
we're in a strange public environment in
which more than half of the American
people don't believe this is a challenge
we at Columbia are very lucky to be part
of extraordinarily rich scientific
environment science environment of the
world's leaders in climate science and I
can tell you what we hear every single
day is that this is a world changer and
we're just on the cusp of disaster our
leading climate scientists James Hansen
who is the US government's lead climate
scientists that the Goddard Institute of
space studies which is at a hundred
thirteenth and broadway and our guru
while we broker at the lamont-doherty
Earth Observatory both in their very
distinctive ways one from the
atmospheric side and the other from the
ocean side and both from the
paleoclimate record carry one
fundamental message which is that the
climate system is profoundly unstable
nonlinear subject to tipping points and
that by all accounts of the paleoclimate
record as well as the physical modeling
of the climate systems as well as what
our colleges and agronomists tell us
about actually observed climate behavior
in recent decades were very very close
to highly nonlinear and highly dangerous
changes in the Earth's environment so
what we're talking about here is one
crucial component of addressing that
problem because the ability to move the
at least a light-duty transport fleet
around the world which itself will grow
phenomenally in the future years as
China becomes the world's largest market
as india's tata nano at two thousand
five hundred dollars sets a new price
point and lee
to tens and then hundreds of millions of
more vehicles on the road the challenge
of finding a way to benefit from
personal mobility but an environmentally
sound manner is one of the greatest
challenges that we face in the world and
the possibility that electric vehicles
open up not only a new Vista of the
quality of life but also a new Vista of
energy systems that are both
environmentally safe and plentiful is
extraordinarily important of course
we're facing another somewhat unknown a
threat but one that is obviously
significant and that's the availability
of conventional oil which is Larry burns
said and of course as everybody knows is
the overwhelming energy source for the
world so that light duty fleet and I
think that it is fair to say that while
the debates about whether peak oil has
arrived or will arrive in 10 years or
will arrive in 20 years or will arrive
in 50 years is a real debate with a lot
of unknowns the security and
availability issues of our conventional
petroleum is a huge question right now
and I would argue that we're in meshed
in war over that very question a very
stupid war in my view but a kind of
conflict that we're going to see more of
unfortunately unless we also find a way
to fundamentally alter our energy system
so it seems to me that we're talking
about something here which is
extraordinarily time-sensitive but also
extraordinarily complex were aiming to
address a quality of life issue that
will be of importance for well over half
the planet very soon which is the well
over half the planet living in the
cities
we are addressing a environmental
security issue of profound significance
and I think we're also addressing
indirectly a national security and a
global security issue and that is how
does a world economy that's already
pressing very hard against the natural
resource base and in my view has already
lifted the real price of oil by a factor
of roughly three during the past ten
years and I think it's likely to stay
high and continue to rise how do we face
these challenges there's also a national
technological challenge which is the
very real point that we're in some
crisis in our industrial and
manufacturing base in this country we
are delighted to see GM on the mend but
we're counting on the Chevy Volt to be
the kind of new leadership that can
allow our national industry also to play
a very significant competitive role in
the world in the years ahead and time is
very sensitive on that as well because
our national economy in my view is in
crisis not just a financial crisis but a
technological challenge let's say that
is a challenge of a much more
competitive world than we faced even 10
or 15 years ago because our competitions
coming from all sides right now so to my
mind the issue here that I'm trying to
understand as a policy analyst and
advisor is the timing what are we what
are we capable of achieving in
transformation to reach scales that will
make a measurable difference on all
three of these dimensions on the
environmental security on the energy
security on the national security I
would say is the second and on the
technological
leadership if we go along at the pace
we're going purely by market forces
alone my view is that this will remain
as many people predict very important
very fascinating very exciting but from
a scale point of view a relatively small
part of a much larger and quite
dangerous story so I believe that we're
in the business not only of trying to
find how to make all of these
complementary systems work but do it in
real time and do it in accelerated time
in policy time now I just testified in
Congress last week on these issues and
we're thrilled by the way with our we we
are already we were represented by the
the former head of the ways it means the
committee whose a temporarily stepped
aside and the new one is our good friend
a good friend of this industry sandy
Levin who called these hearings but I
can say what I already knew beforehand
and after listening to the rest of the
committee knew very well after we have
no national policy on these issues at
all we have some important components
where the government is financing some
technology and batteries is looking for
in providing some incentives for the new
vehicles and is definitely interested in
these issues but to my mind we do not
have a proper framework yet that
addresses the realities of the
technological complexity the role of
public policy the role of infrastructure
the role of energy policy the role of
consumer realities and the role of the
time dimension that is involved in many
of the pre commercial and complex
complementary aspects of this challenge
the administration present
said that he wanted a million electric
vehicles on the road by 2015 good and
specific goal we don't yet have a policy
to achieve a goal like that or two and
we've not stated in I'd say yet a
serious and and national way what kind
of goals we should have 4 2015 4 20 20
20 25 20 30 and how we would get there
we also have the complexity of the
international climate negotiations
because it should be absolutely clear to
everybody that no matter what the United
States does on this unless there is a
global framework for climate change the
world is going to be wrecked and it's
going to be wrecked within the next 40
or 50 years and that means that we need
to take action now because we're talking
about infrastructure and technologies
that are going to already be set in
course for decades to come and so the
issues of the electric vehicles are
partly a national competition issue but
they're also partly a global survival
issue as well that makes this very hard
what is our international policy
perspective on what we're talking about
on the ways that systems design sharing
of technologies shared concepts global
goals global standards should get
integrated as you all know and I know it
very well sitting inside the UN our
international negotiations are in
disarray on all of these issues one of
the main reasons they're in disarray
unfortunately is there is a complete
disjunction between the diplomacy of
negotiations the engineering realities
and the private sector it's as if it's
three completely different worlds and so
one of the things that also needs to be
done is to bring these worlds of the
negotiators the companies and the
technology experts together so all of
this is to say that I'm listening from a
very particular point of view to the
discussion
this is an extraordinarily complex
system of systems that we're talking
about i think everybody made that clear
it is also i and i share the view for
all of the important reasons both what
is potential in the technology for new
quality of life what is needed for the
environment and what is needed for
global security and energy availability
we are at a historic juncture we really
are entering a new era but it's not just
entering the new era it's not just being
pointed in the right direction it's
getting to some real destinations in
time to make the difference that we're
going to need thanks
thanks thanks Geoffrey I've been told we
were running quite late so I despite his
many achievements I'm going to shorten
Tony poza watts's introduction he
currently is this we finally get to the
boat right as the centerpiece Tony
serves as the vehicle line director for
the Chevrolet Volt he's been gee gee I'm
for 25 years he's really pushed this
from day one I think he was employee
number one working on the volt and it's
been brought to market in a pretty quick
manner he's chairman a co-chairman of
the electric drive transportation
association and was responsible for
other vehicles like the Cadillac
Escalade and chevrolet avalanche so Tony
thank you so much I want to first thank
Columbia University and their affiliated
partners for organizing such an event
for some of us in the corporate world
it's truly invigorating to leave the
offices the PowerPoint presentations and
being such a vital campus environment
and so thank you so much for that it's
good for the soul as was stated my name
is Tony paws wats sounds like kilowatts
but pronounced pazza watts and it is
true I do have an Earth Day birthday so
it was fate it was fate that I'd be
destined and dr. burns is one of the
people that helped influence my
appointment into the position of the
vehicle I'm director for the Chevy Volt
so it is all coming together i think i
will talk a little about the Volt today
but I want to first acknowledge and
recognize my fellow panelist I've
learned a lot from them historically
I've learned a lot from them already
today but I will differ with them on a
few things here notice the man from the
general motors company did not bring any
PowerPoint charts I brought a real
drivable car hahaha that's out a college
walk and it will be there out till one
o'clock today so if we do get the
opportunity please in
enjoy some of the sunshine of Earth week
I like how it's changed from Earth Day
to earth week enjoy that take a look at
the car we've got some technical experts
there and I'll tell you a little bit
more about the story of how and when the
car is coming and it is coming the other
ways I difference with my panelists is
the following notice the man from
general motors company is the one
without the tie I have a short sleeve
shirt underneath here I don't even have
a t-shirt it's part of my mask reduction
program to be more efficient had I only
got a haircut before I came here but I
think the comments from the panelists
was we're really wonderful set up it
gives you context about this unique
moment in history that we were upon us
and let me comment a little bit of an
additional point in the time frame that
was illuminated by our keynote speaker
and I used the term illumination on
purpose recently had an opportunity to
meet and spend some time with Daniel
Yergin who many of you know is an
esteemed author pulitzer prize for the
prize and so I read it intently trying
to learn about energy some of the
history where we came from I've done the
same with the history of electric
vehicles and and I think some of our
panelists highlighted some of the long
rich history of electric vehicles
interestingly enough in the prize
there's a fascinating quote from Winston
Churchill and it was really what spurred
I Daniel Yergin to call the book the
prize and it was something to do with
when Churchill was the head of the Navy
in the UK and he had determined what
fuel he was going to use to win his
battles he chose petroleum and he used
the term or the phrase mastery itself is
the price of this venture we've used a
little bit internally on the Chevy Volt
team to say technological leadership and
the ability to use technology and
innovation to solve our problems is
really what we're all about and is
identified by dr. burns of dr. Sachs is
a very very complicated problem but we
have history on how we've worked
together and solve problems like this if
you go back to the day and age when the
oil industry first began it wasn't
gasoline that fueled its growth it was
kerosene
it was touted as the new light it
created the ability for people to read
to become educated so on and so forth we
remember the oil wells in Pennsylvania
it was kerosene that was first the
product not gasoline interestingly
enough innovators and inventors came up
with something and we've got wonderful
colleagues with rich experience and how
the grid came to be how Thomas Edison
created the incandescent light bulb and
truly created the new light replacing
kerosene and kerosene just like gasoline
also had its baggage there was many a
small Hut that was burned down and the
like dr. sacks and I have talked about
some of these opportunities that some of
this innovation and technology could
bring to bear so I thought that context
was helpful because I think it's a very
unique opportunity as stated by my
fellow panelists I'm bringing so many
interesting winds of change together and
they intersect dr. burns is common to me
and many times about something called
the power of and so let's comment a
little bit about six technologies that
are just really gaining momentum but the
synergistic effect of having them work
together is even more powerful and I'll
cite some examples with the Volt and
connecting it to the smart grid as well
the technology's there absolutely
fastening are obviously electric
propulsion and all that goes with that
motors power electronics systems
thinking integration software to remove
these vehicles advanced batteries the
chevy volt battery we'll take what we
typically knowest the lithium-ion cells
in your cell phones I would venture to
guess most of those cell phones
batteries probably don't last more than
a year or two yet with the Volt we will
accelerate the robustness of the design
it will create a battery pack that will
last 10 plus years in a car and perhaps
another ten years outside of the car
talk about a leap frog in the basic
simple cell that you find in your
devices and operating environment mind
you with
temperature changes severe dramatic
humidity vibration one of the harshest
environments that exists so we think
that this is a significant technology
we're taking a leadership position I
with the vault and eventually will
understand more about the power of an
intersection how that helps some of the
other key technologies I referent
technology number three renewable energy
sources if we only could predict when
the wind blows and the Sun shines that
we could be waiting there with our
collectors right when the chevy volt
battery is plugged in hopefully 22 23
hours a day it becomes the ideal
collector most people are not driving at
night although I've had some strange
hours here in the last couple weeks that
have caused me to do that but
nonetheless that's when the wind blows
when you're at work during the day the
infrastructure opportunity that exists
to collect the Sun if you're just
plugged in and I know the people on this
campus are plugged in and we're going to
get you even more plugged in as we go
forward and we talk about the future
when the volt is coming to market smart
grid technology number four was well
stated by some of my colleagues how
important this is to eliminate waste
from the system and so much waste does
exist and we'll talk about how we can
make that a reality fifth technology
spoken to by dr. burns the connected car
and how our lives are connected I have a
fun thing that I do every time I'm on an
airplane and I sometimes chat with the
person next to me I've been known as
someone who engages in discussions and
conversations and I will place a bet on
them as to how many seconds it takes a
number of people that sit in front of us
in the plane when the plane lands to
turn their devices on to get reconnected
it's a very very powerful concept why
can't we now connect our cars to our
devices to our grids to our lifestyle we
have the technology to do that finally
six key technology of really fascinating
interest to me is also the engineered
fuel space where that the biofuel or
some other way to integrate new fuels
and some of the wonderful innovations
and ven shins are occurring there so
amongst these six technologists multiple
intersection points let me comment only
in a couple of them with respect to all
of your time and let me highlight a
feature that General Motors has as it
relates to one of the fundamental strong
pipelines using cellular technology and
this is our OnStar wireless telematics
platform something that many you are
familiar with we've had it in our cars
for the past 14 years the Volt will get
the ninth generation black box of onstar
in it and what does this allow us to do
it certainly allows us to unlock and
lock our cars remotely it allows us to
deploy airbags it allows us to connect
with a safety advisor it allows us to do
a host of other things under the
fundamental guise of safety and security
now recently I had an opportunity to go
to the OnStar command and control center
and a renaissance in Detroit Michigan
and watch live the capability of onstar
applied to the next level what does this
mean we now have the ability not just to
remotely unlock and lock your car we now
have the opportunity when we're advised
of a theft of your car and the right
authorities are involved that we can
literally prevent a high-speed chase
locate that car and safely and securely
d power that car so that that criminal
can be apprehended by the authorities so
I was watching a video of this and the
thing that I found most intriguing at
the end is as the policeman approaches
the car there's obviously no power he
can't move he can't escape he tries to
open the door conveniently the doors
locked on him he tries escaping from the
sunroof and we closed that escape hatch
as well so what does that tell us as it
relates to the various technology
circles in the intersections if we can
stop a car from driving safely and
securely I think we can send a signal to
stop charging if necessary if we're at a
point in time in the middle of August
and three in the afternoon when we need
to shed some load
as it relates to this technology that
just gives you a glimpse of the
possibilities similarly as we collect
data from OnStar from the car we have a
battery doctor on board we'll be
collecting more data just like some of
our friends on the internet collect data
and try to understand what
advertisements you should be sent and so
on and so forth data is powerful and in
the university such as Colombia I think
you know and I'll understand us so it's
it's a very very exciting time when you
think that we do have the technological
pieces we do have the the problem
solvers to connect these dots to connect
the nodes as we stated earlier I think
that's very exciting so it would be
remiss on my part if I didn't at least
finish with a shameless advertisement
for the bolt and I know you would expect
that so please and dolt Chevy old is
here today and we've been driving around
and engaging many a customer in the
product for the last six months or so
very very unusual for a conventional car
let alone a car that is so advanced the
car is being built today as we speak in
production flavors and what does that
mean it means the production version of
the car is at its home plant there are
production parts off of production tools
being assembled to ready this car for
the market to be launched at the end of
this year as you know it's been a well
publicized project and our launch date
has been advertised as November 2010 is
when we will build retail cars between
now and then we will have demonstrations
and we will squeeze out every possible
issue and bug that we can so this car
could be ready for the market and it can
be at your everyday primary vehicle and
be the first mass-market electric
vehicle and hopefully hopefully be an
enabler for a host of other electrically
driven vehicles whether they be pure
battery electric vehicles fuel cell
vehicles and be one of the great
integrators of all these technologies so
I'm sure you are rooting for us wishing
us luck we we feel we're on a very very
good glide path to deliver
this final thoughts are since the theme
of this conference is New York and the
electric car we would very much like to
be bringing this car to the Big Apple to
the surrounding area we have a do a
project with con Edison so they will be
receiving some of the very first cars
later this year and helping us make the
car seamlessly interact with the grid
the new fueling station and I know about
you but i really look forward to the day
where i'm at gas station will be in my
garage and i'll be gassing up my car in
my pajamas when i'm sleeping i really
look forward to that day and it's not
far off so I very much look forward to
working with you in the future I do
believe that your region and area is
organizing itself to be plugging ready
the EVs are coming the Chevy Volt is
coming and thank you for your time
thanks very much timing okay at this
point I'm going to introduce Catherine
Devaney who will then take over for the
rest of the the event Kathleen is the
deputy editor and global business editor
of Newsweek magazine and she oversees
the business and economics technology
coverage of Newsweek including
especially the green rankings franchise
for the magazine which created as an
annual ranking of the 500 largest US
companies she also she had worked
previously at the wall street journal
enter before that at Business Week
magazine and I'll keep it short but
Kathleen welcome
thank you very much I'm going to make a
few comments and then i'm going to ask
our distinguished panelists a few
questions few questions for each of you
and then i'll throw out a few questions
for the whole group and then i'm hoping
that you and the audience will have some
questions that you would like to put to
our panelists anyway I think we all know
that you New York is a very unique
transportation market for instance how
many people drove here today in their
own car anybody okay cameraman good
which is not to say that New Yorkers
don't have cars or don't drive about
forty percent of us own cars but we
drive differently than people in the
rest of the country and i don't mean
more recklessly i mean different times
we tend to drive on the weekends more
they're very different patterns based on
which borough you live in so people here
are driving but it's a different place
in many ways okay i'm going to keep
talking and we grosch our cars
differently most New Yorkers park on the
street or in commercial garages we don't
have our own garages for the most part
which all of which presents kind of
unique challenges but also opportunities
for electric vehicles in this amazing
market but there's also a great need
because just like the overall figure
transportation emissions account for
about twenty-two percent of total New
York greenhouse gas emissions and
electronic vehicles represent a very
clear and obvious way to reduce those
and to help the city meet its overall
sustainability goals so even in New York
where we think of ourselves not driving
that much we have as much work to do as
the rest of the world does introducing
those emissions now there's already a
pretty large group of New Yorkers who
are ready and willing to embrace
electric vehicles according to a pretty
recent study by the Bloomberg
administration up to sixteen percent of
vehicle owners say that they're ready
today to change their behavior start
driving electronic electric vehicles as
soon as they're available which is a
pretty large group and as Tony said next
fall will have the opportunity to
actually buy some commercial vehicles
and start start driving around so
I want to talk to our panelists today
about whether New York is really ready
for the electric car and what do we have
to do to get started on that and so I'm
going to start with Larry you talk very
persuasively about why we need electric
vehicles do we want electric vehicles
are consumers is consumer demand there
are we ready well that that's a great
question because if consumers don't want
them the technology won't scale and
we're not going to solve the problems
what's so exciting about the Volt and
quite honestly 29 other electric
vehicles that are going to come to
market in the next 18 to 24 months 29
you said 20 to 30 in total of one coming
to market over the next two years what
we're going to be able to learn is what
the consumers really want technology
doesn't happen in the auto industry on
one step typically it takes three
commercial learning cycles a commercial
learning cycle is the product and the
hands of real customers made with parts
manufactured by real suppliers Tony said
something real important the Volt's now
being produced with production parts
that were used built with production
tools very hugely important step and so
we go through three cycles and we're
going to learn what customers really
want and we're going to understand what
suppliers can really deliver and that
probably will mature at about the year
2020 so I think there are customers who
are ready and they're going to be our
NASA astronauts for this initial
missions we're going to learn from them
and then we're going to get more
customers and more customers and then
the thing will tip and that's what we
have to drive to what do you think is
the biggest psychological barrier to
getting people into this car range
anxiety and that's why concepts like the
Volt and the Fisker Karma are so
important because they've taken that off
the table that's not to say some of
these other electric vehicles won't have
important learning opportunities that do
not have range extenders but a customer
simply doesn't want to make a trade off
on convenience and safety and security
and the use of their time right and so
if suddenly you're inconvenient
because you don't have enough range or
your concern that you're going to be
stranded somewhere and you're going to
have to wait to plug your car around
that's just a real customer concerned so
I even more southern price of the
vehicle do you think well that's another
important issue the cost will come down
over time and the US government's
playing an important role to provide tax
incentives to get this started the
lithium-ion battery has a potential to
reach a cost target of about 200 to 250
dollars per kilowatt hour and we're
going to have to take the number of
kilowatt-hours down the Volt has 16
kilowatt hours and we're going to have
to take that cost of the battery today
which is significantly higher than the
two of 50 but we'll do that by learning
and so we have to stick with this I may
I'll be very disappointed if the story
is told based totally on first reactions
either overland overly negative right
we're launching an entirely new dynamic
we have to give it a little bit time
yeah we've got to stick with this way
off tomorrow RT it's a beautiful day to
day kind of hard to imagine August right
now but what about that hot August day
at three o'clock in the afternoon what
do we need to do to make sure that our
grid is stable enough at that point to
support the additional energy we will
need for electric vehicles well at those
relatively few hours of the year days of
the year I think that there are
technologies we just heard about one
that the OnStar is developing so I'm
optimistic that those hurdles are very
solvable and the integration of
information with energy as the smart
grid is developed will alleviate that
problem so I don't see that as a
showstopper look I'm definitely not so
we're ready now we're ready now
especially in the early years we just
were hearing about the the cycles of
introduction of products right that's
going to take some time and uh that that
so you're saying demand additional
demand will ramp up slowly ramp up slow
roll early
right and that that learning experience
on the vehicles is equally important in
terms of the learning experience on the
grid and being able to be able to match
this demand it's not like we haven't
seen the introduction of new
technologies before right there's the
introduction of computer technology and
the implications is a Don on energy
growth and use of course are the air
conditioning in the 50s and 60s and the
electrification of the kitchen in the
example stick example so that so that
this is this is I think something that
that our industry is it seen before and
as responded and ran that's and that's
going to be our challenge right well as
one of the forty percent of New Yorkers
who do own a car where do i plug my
electric vehicle in do we need public
charging stations and if so who's going
to be in charge of building them and
maintaining them uh yes I think that we
buy large do need charging stations and
John Gilbert mentioned one of the
opportunities he sees in his buildings
is providing charging infrastructure and
I think that this is again an
opportunity and Economic Opportunity
business opportunity for many people to
differentiate their services to create
new services to create value in in
different ways in garages in and even in
some public spaces okay great Roger
we're talking about marrying together
some extremely complex systems across
many disciplines what about the human
capital aspect of this or do we have the
proper are we training the right kind of
engineers do we need to think about how
engineers are trained differently
absolutely yes the system of systems
requires system of systems engineers and
that does not sit easily within silos of
traditional departments and the talent
will probably drive this on the campus
here at Columbia the most active and
most innovative energy group is led
totally by the students in fact they're
about the only ones who have gotten sepa
the school of international Public
Affairs to talk the engineering school
to talk to their tents to do something
they're the ones who are in all of these
organizations and I believe that the
force will will come from students who
want to do this for a living okay it's
like the early days of the flower
generation right this role it will call
it we're running out of letters XYZ
generation but we need a new kind of
engineer basically we need we need a
much broader or more cross the Lord
trained engineer have been a specialist
okay so when we have those engineers and
we're working on the next generation of
the smart grid have we made the kind of
capital investment that we need to to
move on to the next level well I've been
talking around the country for a group
of seems to be being led by universities
I've been over to Arizona State and to
rice and talking to about what we do
after the stimulus money runs out so the
smart grid is putting a lot of money
into New York City 370 million dollars
the largest investment by the federal
government in any city in America but
what happens after three years we
fundamentally believe there won't be a
follow-up from the Fed the feds you
don't believe they'll be a follow-up no
stimulus money is an extra appropriation
and it's doubtful that
that that commitment can be continued by
a department of energy for instance and
so it's really in our court philanthropy
plus plus academia plus industry and to
sustain this over the 20 to 30 years it
will take to put a million electric
vehicles into New York City I think
that's what Jeff talking about a
challenge i believe is probably one of a
government policy rather than technology
right and then as he was saying also
it's a place where we have to bring the
negotiators together so i just wanted
that i was once told an engineer is a
person who likes to work with numbers
but doesn't have the personality to be
in the countin account and all but but
from my own experience there is nothing
more interesting than what we're working
on right now right and we have to go
beyond interesting we have to get it
over the goal line we have to scale it
in the marketplace but this is really
exciting this really could be truly a
disruptive technology as we were saying
and the opportunities are at the
interfaces and that's why we need the
systems of systems perspectives and I
think the engineers are gonna going to
lead us elsewhere I really do okay
Jeffrey eight um specifically when
you're talking about New York City if
you can bring it down to that kind of
scale what kind of health benefits can
we see right away from converting to
electric cars or or more to the point
what level of kind of penetration do we
need to see before we start realizing
some health benefits that's a tough
question um you know I saved the hardest
one for you well I mean Emma and I'm not
not qualified to give a thorough answer
to that in in any way clearly what we're
talking about here is not only the
vehicle but what happens and not just
the grid but how the energy is produced
what that means for air quality also for
Public Safety as larry was talking about
how the cars actually draw
than what happens to what happens to the
traffic flow so from a public health
point of view there are many aspects of
this there's the energy aspects there's
the traffic safety aspects and so forth
I think one of the things we haven't
really talked about enough talk about
how the grid can be managed we haven't
talked about the challenge for New York
and nationally for what kinds of energy
we really are going to be putting into
the grid right and here the problem is
pretty serious in the sense that all
these wonderful alternatives which we
all want all have their own complex
problems around them we've not yet and
I'm not up to date on this but it's been
very hard to get agreement of
communities to put in upgraded grid
infrastructure for example to carry
renewables on direct current because of
bigger towers and the community is not
wanting to grid to to pass through their
area we've had a difficulty with getting
even a first demonstration project of
carbon capture and sequestration which
is another way to clean up the grid
there's a proposed project in Jamestown
New York and the community says we love
this technology could you do with 5,000
miles away find out how it works right
and then after a few demonstrations so
we'll have it here so I'm pretty
impressed on about the fact that we have
so many complex pieces to this that
we've not really focused on I I knew and
we all know about nimby and we all have
come to learn about num be not under my
backyard with carbon capture but I had
not heard until last week banana which
everybody probably knows but it don't
absolutely nothing anywhere anytime
and we are familiar with that right the
number of projects that are now delayed
on every kind of power plant every kind
of grid facility in our country is very
very large so it's true in New York
State it's true nationally and this is
where I think the political leadership
will be key to breaking through some of
these barriers right um let me just step
back and go global for a second what is
the role of EVs in global development
and sustainability is this is this
something that we're going to see being
adapted in developing markets and
different ways or do you think it's
something that the United States will
pioneer oh I think this is incredibly
important issue because first of all the
world is now more than half urban to
begin with so we're talking about at
least at the the beginning and urban
technology that is going to find a need
all over the world the world's biggest
cities by and large are going to be in
the developing countries in the future
almost all the mega cities third these
cities are building out their
infrastructure for the first time in
many cases and this is that's the
opportunity to get on a path that makes
sense and of course so we are seeing
we've seen this year China overtake the
US as the world's largest automobile
market and I think will never never see
the u.s. overtake China again because
that's a market that is subject to
phenomenal growth although it's such a
crowded country it really poses a lot of
questions about how many what kind of
automobile penetration in the long term
all the experts here would know better
than I but in any event these issues are
absolutely a fundamental significance to
the developing world which is going to
be the place where most of the
automobiles in the future are sold ended
because that's where 56 of humanity
lives right now and so any leader that
one talks to these days and recently
spoke to
were the President of Mexico about this
and he's asking well what about mexico
city is a place to get started to city
of 20 million people with major
environmental challenges and extreme
interest in this but you think about
China India Brazil this issue is an
absolute global issue we're going to
face global competition no question
about it on who's actually going to come
up with with the models right great
thank you Tony we've established i think
in earlier conversations and listening
to the comments that range anxiety is a
big issue for for consumers so what how
do I know when I'm on the Taconic that
my volt isn't going to run out of power
great great question and it's been
something that was referenced previously
that has been an anchor around the
technology for a long time certain
characteristics of battery technology
and one of the reasons General Motors
embarked on the Chevy Volt is we felt
the lithium-ion technology and family of
chemistry's was a nice point to build
off of because of it was increased power
and energy density so it's been a a
problem for electric vehicles for the
last 110 years now many people are
offering different solutions for
extending the range because frankly as
much as we hear about many customers
wanting to be green right the green in
their wallet is still dictating their
actions and behaviors as such one of the
ways that we have constructed the Volt
architecture the propulsion system
architecture and the light is so that it
can create a solution to the range
anxiety exists with batteries that we
know of today there are ways to increase
this this range phenomenon there are
multiple opportunities for charging you
can go into faster charging you can go
into
maybe changing out your battery you can
go into different ways to create
electricity on board the vehicle right
to extend your range the really key
point was from our perspective at
General Motors is that until you solve
the issue of range anxiety you would
never be able to make an electric drive
vehicle mass market because customers do
not want to make the compromises right
there have been electric vehicles for so
many years so many different attempts
and efforts and i'm not sure what the
largest single volume was but for
example the Tesla certainly it's price
prohibitive for many people I'm not sure
if they've hit their thousandth unit yet
or well if they'll ever go much more and
i recently read that the Roadster will
at some point in time move on to another
product move on to another line if you
will and it gets the Larry's point about
the generations of learning and
technology and in probing the market and
understanding the one thing I can say is
I have I have suffered from range
anxiety for as part of the new GM I
think we try to spend more time driving
electric vehicles not just our own right
but others I've driven the mini e here
in Manhattan before and I've not been
able to connect with a friend because he
was worried he wouldn't get back to
white plains and said we actually met in
Colombia vs down on the stock exchange
in a host a different vehicle so i think
you know kind of to the the points made
by the other panelists it has to be
consumer-focused it has to be stainable
sustainable from a business perspective
and you have to have a model to get
there and i think there are some nice
innovative technologies and choices out
there we believe the extended range
feature on the Volt today tell us about
the range of the volt and absolutely
right now we have high confidence that
the Volt will provide up to 40 miles for
most customers and this is completely on
power from the grid stored in your
battery seamlessly if your battery gets
to a point where you have consumed the
amount of kilowatt energy event of
available for use they're usable for the
battery to drive your 40 miles we
seamlessly turn on an engine generator
set and we can go without refueling or
stopping
additional 300 miles and so as dr. burns
indicated you now have the choice of
close to 170,000 fueling stations or I
don't know how many millions of plugs
there are but I can't believe this quite
a few the Volt was also designed based
on the size of its pack that you can
overnight with a simple portable cordsen
120 volt cord set we call it an EV SC
for the engineering students out there
electric vehicle supply equipment write
it down learn about it it's going to be
an important connector umbilical cord as
I reference from the transportation
sector to our friends in the utility
sector we can charge that vehicle
without special equipment or apparatus
overnight eight hours when you're
sleeping with a 240-volt you know
dropping your dryer outlet if you will
it's about a three hour charge and we're
going to anticipate people will get as
many charges in as possible hopefully at
your office or at your University of the
like dr. sex I think you have some
influence you can get a few charging
stations yeah okay and so the concept of
range anxiety is real we have some
solutions we think and I think in the
future other technologies will emerge
whether the battery or otherwise and I
think it's just the most exciting time
but I do really want to emphasize that
the range anxiety concept is real and if
you look at the sort of the behavior
from people if you know you only had one
hundred miles of range you think that
people are driving 80 90 miles no they
cut in half if you have variation around
that range as it relates to temperature
that decreases it more and if the car
becomes not usable or not useable in
certain seasons then I think we've lost
the battle we've lost the battle because
and this is historically what's troubled
the electric vehicle and that he just
didn't mean enough enough people's
lifestyle so we're going to break
through that barrier and as dr. burns
indicated that we see in many other
vehicles coming and as as the commercial
goals may the best car win right and how
much will develop cost the volt or live
electrical well where's my PR guy
we plan to announce our pricing later
this summer not even a range can't give
us any analogy let me let me comment
here because I think dr. Sachs really
referenced some key points as well in
order to support the technology during
its early stages we're very pleased that
the federal government and other
entities are providing sort of that
cushion if you will to get people
interested in adopting technology okay
the Volt itself is a Chevrolet right and
the desired state is to make it a little
bit more than a comparable compact car
so we believe when one compiles
ultimately the value proposition which
includes perhaps all the OnStar and
mobile app features the difference
between electricity and gasoline the
incentives and interestingly enough I
think there's going to be some very
significant announcement the next month
or two on the launch regions but
ultimately I think you'll find that this
car may be the equivalent of less than a
thirty thousand dollar car great so be
careful about the price I will well
that's what my answer was a little
lengthy no but you gave us a category to
think about and now I'm going to throw
out a question to all of you and then
ask for some questions from the audience
but again we talked about how New York
is such a unique market what's the role
for electronic vehicles in mass transit
or in the taxi fleet here how what steps
need to happen for that to move forward
obviously as art said where we all rely
on electric transportation more than
many cities through the subway but what
has that what else has to happen here
art maybe I'll start with you since and
then I'll come back to you dr. Bernstein
um I i think the the point you bring up
about fleets i think that that is a
unique opportunity it was speaking to
some of the folks who do package
delivery who I won't name specifically
but they specifically mentioned that
their everage daily route in manhattan
from garage out to the route that they
take to deliver the packages back to the
garage is a little less than nine miles
so that
kind of of vehicle use this interesting
sell local delivery local delivery and
so that that kind of fleet the so
delivery fleets were taxis are a bit
problematic because they are because of
the cost of the of the medallion and all
are neat to be out on the road there
doesn't seem to be much opportunity for
recharge really but but the idea of fast
charging and a battery swap outs might
fit that fleet it's interested so I and
there may be other other technology
solution dr. ins yeah I want to go back
to the point I made about mass earlier
um actually a year ago I was in New York
City and we revealed a vehicle at the
time it was called Puma personal urban
mobility and accessibility picture of
segue and widen the wheels and have two
people sit on it and cover it a vehicle
away about 750 pounds now transit bosses
64 passengers so it's 32 two passenger
seats two rows and 16 seats now picture
32 of these pumas following each other
closely side by side you can actually
move more people in those vehicles than
you can with the bus the 32 weighed less
than a bus so they're more efficient and
the 32 will cost less than a bus the key
is to redefine how we're moving around
and used the technology communications
transportation and energy technology the
convergence of that to change the game
the DNA of the car is 120 years old how
many industries are out there that have
hundred and twenty year old product DNA
and the reason it's 120 years old is
there's a codependence that's existed
that fed on itself so we need to change
that dynamic so I think there's a very
exciting future in New York City a
transit is great i'm not saying it's not
an important part of it but if we can
move around without the taxi cabs in New
York City do a very quietly dil very
politely
so we're not running into each other do
it without any missions utilize the
electric grid but in this case you're
making much more efficient use of the
electricity okay three kilowatt hour
battery versus a 16 kilowatt hour
battery on the vote so I think I mean
there's huge opportunities in the city I
do want to encourage everybody to pay
attention to what's going on in shanghai
at the world expo that the purpose of
that expose better city better life
they're looking at the year 2030 through
the lens of a major asian city and i
think not just for transportation
technology everything it's going to be
critically important and you can pay
attention to it not just by going there
but by seeing what you can get off of
the web it's going to be really
fascinating do we have any questions in
the audience let me follow though I'm
sorry one point I happen that is the
thing I'm most worried about in terms of
electric transportation in New York City
is the bad shape our subways are in so
you guys out there ought to think about
how you can help the MTA to modernize
the most efficient electricity
transportation system that we already
have what does it carry five million
that day 5 million a day 24 hours a day
and it's in bad shape thank you yes sir
Vijay Modi had a question first of all
love the panel need more events like
this two questions one is we talked
about integration of transportation and
the building or the home today
seventy-five percent of end use in a
home is for hot water and space heating
nearly all of it coming from fossil
fuels how can that get in be taught in
an integrated way across transportation
and electricity as well so that's one
question the second question was in my
hometown in India they legislated that
all taxis be compressed natural gas they
are low speed they don't look that much
unlike the Puma but they are called
rickshaws and they get more than 100
miles a gallon equivalent if our grid is
going to come from natural gas before it
comes from a solar or wind what do you
think is the role of compressed natural
gas for vehicles let's start with the
first question he would like to take
that on ok can I just comment on those
figures for heating and how order are
using electricity that that's not the
case in New York City I'll get odd then
I misunderstood the question so so tell
me I'm sorry tell me you're questioning
the first question again could you
clarify the question law how can the
heating and hot water end users which
are all fossil fuel derived from oil and
natural gas how can they be thought in
an integrated way across transportation
electricity and heat the panel was
addressing the integration of
transportation and electric and my
question is how did the third end use
which is for heat and you know gives
artists brother yes there there are some
future technologies that that go to that
kind of integration one of them is a
home fuel cell embedded in the hot wood
heater that creates electric
city and the waste heat heats the water
and the water is used for space heating
as well and then the electricity could
be used for charging a vehicle or for
other uses of electricity so there are
appliances and that have been developed
that are beginning to look at that level
of integration how about compressed
national yeah natural thing I think that
I'm really glad you brought up natural
gas 10-15 years ago the United States
was planning major ports to bring
liquefied natural gas into the United
States from Russia in the Middle East
because we are concerned we had a
shortage over twenty year period
technology has been developed called
hype hydraulic fracturing basically to
extract natural gas from shale deposits
of which of the US has for very large
shale deposits the reserves now the
United States for natural gas are very
very large and that's exciting because
natural gas is relatively clean fossil
fuel versus oil and vs col now there's
three ways you can use natural gas for
transportation you can compress it and
burn it in an internal combustion engine
you can burn it at a power plant make
electricity for a plug-in electric
vehicle or you can strip the four
hydrogen's off the carbon and make
hydrogen for fuel cell electric vehicle
so go back and do the calculations
engineers and ask yourself which will
you go for farthest on with a cubic foot
of natural gas putting it in a
compressed engine and burning it burning
at a power plant for a plug-in or
tornado an end to a hydrogen in effect
the plug-in and hydrogen option are much
more attractive than the internal
combustion engine option there is an
application of compressed natural gas I
think that's going to make a lot of
sense and that's with them class 8
trucks and deliveries within cities and
things because the diesel engine doesn't
have a lot of good alternative so I
think compressed natural gas can play
there and what while I have the mic I
also want the engineers to do the
calculation if you have an acre or a ton
of biomass and you can turn it into
ethanol
or you could burn it and make
electricity for a battery or you could
turn it into hydrogen which we go far
this done and in that case you go
farthest with the hydrogen and the fuel
so the good news is we have a lot of
biomass it's non food based we have a
lot of natural gas and you can use each
of those three ways for transportation
come on there's a solution just sitting
there for us to be had on domestically
produced energy if we can get off the
oil and get on to electrically driven
vehicles and these are their own options
RT did you have something to add yes I
there currently are two or three
compressed natural gas stations in New
York City and the number is growing and
the principal vehicles that that come up
to that pump our taxicabs and some small
trucks so the infrastructure is already
exists and the plan is that that that
infrastructure will be increased one is
missing now it's in is vehicles that are
built for compressed natural gas right
now most of those vehicles perhaps all
of them are converted conversions
aftermarket conversions of commercially
available vehicles so we agree that
electric vehicles aren't are one of
several alternatives compressed natural
gas biofuels and and others are out
there as well Roger did you have
something yet one last comment I was
with Dow Chemical as a city in Texas
entire city called Freeport which got 10
petrochemical plants and we were talking
about transportation uses of natural gas
it's a tremendous waste to take natural
gas and propel automobile with one
person in it compared to making plastics
that they would take first claim i
believe on the natural gas
an electricity generation would take
second claim and i doubt if
transportation is very high up on that
list good next question yes I'm Jim
motivala from the New York Times and I
do think one of the elephants in the
room which we haven't addressed is the
question of we are in New York City here
and most people do live in apartment
buildings and park their cars on the
street and I was talking to fellow from
Kalume which is one of the big charging
companies and he had a BMW mini e they
told me took a month for him to get
approvals through the city government to
be able to get his charging station
because you have to go through the city
and you have to go get the incentive
inspectors come out the whole process is
very delayed this is for a residential
home yeah to have a charging station or
a garage and saw this is for people who
have garages it takes a month to get
that approved so we're looking at people
who parked cars on the street in New
York City where I imagine a tangle of
different agencies have jurisdiction and
one can imagine that this could be a
very prolonged process with that I'm not
sure we've totally worked out yet we've
sort of addressing this on the macro
level and I think we need to address it
on the micro level 2 bike on the street
how do you charge your car how will we
charge our cars RT can you I I'd like to
second that observation and I I think
that unfortunately a professor Sachs
left that is a domain where policy at a
local level would be very beneficial to
be able to untangle that that series of
approvals that are needed to get that
that charging infrastructure there's
also the emergence of commercial
entities that are looking at that very
problem and and trying to figure out how
they could perhaps build
in charging infrastructure in the
streets so you just write it companies
that we are actors just like you see in
fact right just like you see the boots
it at bus stops just like you see
telephone telephone booths on the
sidewalk that there'd be some
streetscape system that would provide
charging infrastructure for vehicles
that are plugged that are parked at the
curb Tony what do you have big an issue
is that from let me let me comment a
little bit Jim good seeing you by the
way thanks for coming from a volt
perspective we recognized some of the
administrative challenges associated
with that and that's why the Volt is
very much geared towards not special
apparatus but basically find the plug in
the wall and charge your vehicle
overnight now in big cities and
environments like New York that is
certainly a different challenge but I
harken back to the challenge in the
context of is it a technological
challenges in adventure or is it an
organizational challenge I like to tell
the story when we first were questioned
and queried about our ability to make
batteries General Motors and I bodily
told them the story did you know that
General Motors had batteries on the moon
because General Motors was the battery
developer and manufacturer for the three
lunar Rovers we also designed the
electric propulsion system in the
software for Apollo 15 16 and 17 it just
so happens that Apollo 17 the lunar
rover went 22 miles I don't know if it's
real world miles or lunar miles but 22
miles and unfortunately the program was
scrapped due to no recharging
infrastructure so point being is if we
can do these kind of technological
accomplishments this is a little bit why
we're here today I think this is a
little bit why we reach out to you and
share with you the progress we're making
this is sort of it takes a plug-in ready
community and I think Jim's point was
spot-on I mean if we can just cut
through the permitting process I was
with David's and below yesterday
since the secretary of Department of
Energy and he says he wanted to say he
thinks if we can't accomplish that and
sort certainly the New Yorkers I know if
they band together with with the key
leaders we see here today and the
thought leaders we hate to see around
the air I'm confident we can figure out
a way now remind you early on we won't
have that many vehicles so it's the
perfect time to start figuring out how
to establish a main charging station for
someone in most cases in the Midwest at
someone's garage in their home or a
place of work but it's a wonderful
opportunity and challenge for us to
collectively problem solve the gentleman
hi my name is Bruce link and I'm the
entrepreneur in residence here at the
Columbia School of Engineering where do
you see opportunities for creating new
jobs that could also help stimulate
economic growth here in the city of New
York let me start off a little bit with
my home state state of Michigan which
has been very very hard hit during the
last economic time and just give you
some factoids on what we have
accomplished over the last year or so
and I think given the the talent that
you have here and the resources the like
I think the the the other opportunities
abound in the last shirt period of time
we have invested over seven hundred
million dollars in the state of Michigan
and that has provided us a that's just
for the bulk just just related to the
vote what that has done is it's spun off
diddle little spin off industries it's
involved universities because you need
trained in talat individuals and you
need the software and connections if you
will so that includes a vehicle assembly
plant detroit hamtramck a brand new
battery plant in brownstown michigan
state of the art we've had two
investments in the state of the art
probably world-class battery laboratory
facility cell manufacturing facility if
you include beyond the seven or million
i referenced in some investments outside
the company we're creating a corridor
you know a hub of this activity when I
would encourage new york to do and i
think you guys have the wherewithal i've
seen some great signs
organizing your area you create a hub of
a plug in readiness and then there's a
whole host of different opportunities
whether it's solar panels on top of the
charging stations and I had various
venues whether it's places of business
whether it's small fleets I think the
learning exercise of generating some of
these little initiatives will spawn
other other opportunities and I think
the most interesting opportunity is the
education and the knowledge base that
you accumulate those that move first in
this space I'm convinced well we'll
think of the next best idea and then
obviously get some benefits i personally
think the use of the battery and if you
get some familiar with using the battery
and charging it can do some wonderful
things as i talked about collecting
renewable energy i think at some point
in time we may have batteries in our
homes and you want to talk about an
interesting perspective that that
provides and affords us relative to
having control of your opponent energy
so a great question all right i yes the
the car increasingly is was pointed out
this is becoming an electronic device
and software and the intelligence and
the development of that software and the
technicians and the types of level of
capability that are needed for that that
provides a unique opportunity for
education as well as to the training for
the train mechanics and technicians the
there's some great work going on in the
state and specifically in New York City
in developing advanced battery
technologies there's some amazing
technology I saw it at City at City
College so we see work and potentially
the materials that those batteries are
made of are available and fabric could
be fabricated anywhere as a matter of
fact that makes a lot more sense to
fabricate some of those batteries closer
to the use so beers I believe this
displaces jobs that are offshore now in
the production of the fuels that we use
now and brings them on shore and New
York City is
a great place for those kinds of up can
you imagine the idea of what we're
talking about here of displacing all the
petroleum that we import with
domestically created and produced fuels
with the you know the new inventions
with the you know kind of the six
technologies i referenced and again the
talented individuals we have on this
campus in this state so I'm going to do
a little plug p.m. Fletcher's he or she
is our chief engineer for propulsion
systems under volt and she has other
responsibilities and plug-in
technologies and hybrid technologies so
if there's any engineers who are
interested Pam I'm sure she'll collect
your resume because again we are
intending to grow this business and to
your very point to create some green
jobs out of this right thank you next
question please my name is Robert
Sinclair jr. I'm the media spokesman for
triple-a New York my right chest rise
for our magazine car and travel mention
the psychological barrier of range
anxiety with electric vehicles would
throw a couple others out there number
one charging times which you kind of
touched on the idea that one of your
competitors Nissan Leaf it'll get 100
miles on a charge and then conceivably
need a six seven or eight hour charge
would seem to be a barrier and also
performance you talk about the unique
driving environment here in New York
we've got a lot of poorly engineered
roads which mean you have to accelerate
very quickly to get in front of that
100,000 pound big rig and it seems that
electric vehicles of pretty much down on
performance you know the bolt has a
sport mode I have to drive it briefly
and it seemed like it would be a way to
deal with that problem but most part
electric vehicles are pretty slow and a
couple of other things the batteries
that are going to be in these vehicles
what happens when it's time to get rid
of them are they going to be recyclable
with the lethality or the toxic or what
have you and with all these vehicles of
the future going to be connected and
talking to each other and not crashing
is our driver training program going to
be put out of business we are talking
dresses you guys one of whom yeah I'm
afraid that one's coming to you teddy
huh great question i'm glad you had the
opportunity to drive the bolt so remind
me as we go along as
couple of those areas but let me start a
little bit on an area I know quite why
electric vehicle performance one of the
beauties about electric drive and this
comes comes right from the heart from
having driven as many cars as I've
driven is the delightful driving
experience if the vehicle is designed
correctly electric drive gives you a
couple of things the term instantaneous
torque sounds very technical but it is
very exhilarating anyone who's familiar
with gasoline-powered cars they work
their way up to a torque curve your
engine revving get the appropriate spot
that's where you get your peak power on
a vehicle like the Chevy Volt an
electric drive vehicle you get your
instantaneous torque immediately matter
of fact the vehicle you drove we had a
lag put in so you wouldn't burn the
tires our prototype tires so just so you
know I even even even in regular mode
the Chevy Volt will be zero to 60 in
less than nine seconds and the
instantaneous torque will will have the
feel of a car that's maybe about a 250
horsepower v6 equivalent so if the
vehicle is designed properly electric
drive in the instantaneous torque is a
wonderful experience for managing the
scenario situation you referenced you
want to stop I ask you a question
because I I too had a 65 Mustang and I
know Dave and I would like to have it
make really cool sound you've got to put
any kind of like false well one of the
things one of the things that one of the
things about the technology we're
talking about here and all the software
and advanced nature of it is you guys
are familiar with one point 0 2 point 0
3 point 0 and this is why we come here
so don't be surprised if some future
volts that one point oh I offer you some
of that that capability so let's let's
get back to it so what about the
disposal of batteries is a different at
present different issues and
conventional car batteries let me let me
kind of rewind to the comments I made we
immediately took the step and saying
take battery technology and extend it
and push it as far as you can relative
to long-term performance that gets the
ability to use the kilowatt hours of
energy the capacity as long as possible
because the
technology is relatively robust based on
our testing of effectively millions of
electric miles on our cyclers and on the
roads so the volt battery for example if
you would consider 80 to 100 percent
capacity range we use a little over half
the battery pack that allows it to last
a long time it allows us possibly to
modify the state of charge window in the
future to give you consistent range
performance and allows us to extend the
life of the battery we also condition
the battery when it's plugged in it is
kept at a temperature we've we've
referred to the battery as our diva she
is temperature control she's got her own
heating and cooling system liquid-cooled
system and the very intent is the longer
you can extend the life and usable life
of the battery the less you have to
worry about recycling when the battery
after 10 years is considered no longer
automotive grade it still has about
seventy percent of its capacity
available and theoretically oval that
still be driven but instead of 40 miles
you may now get 28 25 miles and you just
use the extended range feature more so
we could drive it even longer so we're
we're pretty convinced and confident
it'll be 10 plus years in the car plus a
life outside of the car and then to your
final question as you look at the
covariance components the electronics
the metal the plastics and how you
extract lithium it is quite easily too
easily to recycle now there are no
large-scale commercial businesses today
that do that there will be there will be
what about the future of reducing
charging times again in a volt 240 volt
is a three hour charge the Nissan Leaf
you reference is an eight hour charge
240 it's a 16 plus regular so we chose a
little less battery because it costs
less weighs less gives you more room in
the car takes less time to charge and if
you get an extra plugin you don't need
to have that really big battery so this
is the way we've chose the solution
there is some interesting things and you
know you might want to comment on fast
charging because I think that's an
interesting technology
there are several other options and
again realizing this is a one point 0
tech technology the high voltage 440
volt level three is it's called charging
though that has a very significant
impact on the grid so it requires a kind
of an intermediate storage DC storage
usually and that allows for recharging
within 10-15 minutes is the kind of the
kinds of design basis and for that kind
of a system also there are other ideas
of creating battery packs that could be
swapped out so the car would be
equivalent to a being gassed up at a
pump there there's also the kind of use
pattern studies that a need to be done
typically a car might be used an hour or
two a day so depending upon the
pervasiveness of recharging that leaves
22 or 23 hours to recharge so with six
hour charges not at all infeasible it's
matt fact it fits very well but that
would require pretty pervasive
availability of places to charge so the
this whole question of and what the leaf
people with the Nissan people told us is
that that hundred mile range is is
something because we asked the same
question that 100-mile range is really a
covers a huge percentage of people's
driving patterns and what they found was
just the availability of even a very few
one or two or three charging stations in
a downtown area alleviates the
psychological anxiety it's not a real
issue it is an anxiety so that as
drivers
are more used to that kind of fuel and
adjust their thinking that that's less
and less of a problem in Manhattan I
have range anxiety every time I bring my
car in because there are almost no gas
stations so so that I saw that that's
the the challenge of we see I I think
you could tell your membership at I'm
being one of them that I think that this
is something that's that's going to be a
lot of fun to drive I've driven a bunch
of these they're terrific vehicles I
wish these guys well in and and I wish
them success both from the viewpoint of
I like the drive and it's a it's a
terrific car but also that we happen to
be the electric company and we have no
intent of eliminating your driver
programs trust me one last point on that
already could correct correct me but the
city of Paris the city government is
putting in the charging stations yes any
any sign the New York City my
administration might do something like
that now not young Thank You the last
question please um I came a few minutes
late so hopefully this hasn't already
been covered but looking at sort of
municipal charging stations or private
ones I was wondering maybe already would
notice if there were companies like
better place that's going on in israel
and i know i think in denmark if there
are private companies like those that
have been in conversations with you or
that we can see the seeds of you know a
swap dune program going in already and
my second very quick question was if
there have been any either municipal or
company fleets or things like programs
like Zipcar that have put out like a
potential initial commitment to get us
from the early adopter phase to bring
this up the scale if there have been any
sort of commitments of company fleets
question the first question uh there
have been at least three commercial
suppliers of charging systems that have
gotten to speak to us and describe their
plans they are very interesting very
different approaches better place being
one of them and they're just trying to
figure out what would make sense for New
York City and we're working with them
they try and help them the other is is
the other question in terms of there has
been any fleet commitments for all
companies or mogy like car rental not
leave you know places that would have
the infrastructures maybe already in
there lots were like as you know zip car
or something where they could already
you know people might be using them for
short amounts of times they would have
that right the way I understand Zipcars
is that they park in commercial
facilities so they would and they would
engage in in in some arrangements with
those and it would seem reasonable that
they would do that there have been a
number of fleets that that have
approached us that were planning our
some stage of planning of putting in
charging infrastructure at their
facilities with it they would have a
fifty or a hundred vehicles that could
charge so those conversations have
started I wouldn't characterize them
though is serious they're just
exploratory so there haven't been any
sort of initial commitment like an
objection as the parking garage people
who own large perking those well I can't
specifically say oh they are but the
first one the first one wonderful we
talked about public yes we have had
three significant providers of parking
that have approached us people who own
fleets it's more exploratory thank you
did that answer question I don't know I
guess I was sort of looking for names
but right now for now
yes but it's it's it's it's the and
these conversations started about a year
ago so and I know there's there they're
thinking in their levels of commitment
are are serious and as they see the
vehicles coming to market they're
looking to be early adopters they want
to differentiate themselves and and
create a place and I think this is all
going to be happening very soon thank
you well I'd like to thank all of our
panelists very much you've been great
today and I want to thank columbia and
the School of Engineering and also the
audience for asking such good questions
thank you very much for coming